today's episode is brought to you by
curiositystream an incredible and
Incredibly affordable place to watch
thousands of non-fiction movies and
shows more on them in a bit
John Gotti was all smiles as he walked
out through the doors of the courthouse
still a free man it wasn't the first
time that he'd beat the rap and it
wouldn't be the last that's why people
called him the Teflon Don because no
charges would stick to him outside the
building his adoring public was waiting
for him one of them enthusiastically
shouted out queen says two world
champions the Mets and John Gotti John
Gotti was more than just a successful
Mafia Don he changed the way the people
regarded mob bosses he never shied away
from the spotlight or even tried to hide
the fact that he was the most powerful
criminal in New York City he embraced
this Persona and became the first
mediadon always ready to pose for the
camera in order to show off his new
thousand dollar double-breasted suit his
perfectly coiffed hair or the beautiful
lady hanging off his arm John Gotti
thought he was Untouchable he started
out as a small time Gangster in Queens
and Rose up to become the head of the
gambino crime family leaving a trail of
dead bodies behind him that would make
Macbeth blush and this even included the
previous boss Paul Castellano whom Gotti
had murdered and still ended up with his
no hose clean so it's not surprising
that he thought nobody could mess with
him but you know how it goes you're only
Untouchable until you're not and that's
a lesson that John Gotti learned the
hard way
[Music]
John Joseph Gotti Jr was born on October
27 1940 in South Bronx the 5th of 13
children to a second generation Irish
immigrants John and Franny Gotti when he
was a young child his family moved
around the city a lot eventually
settling in East New York in Brooklyn
wherever he went though Gotti saw first
hand the wide reach of the mafia he
didn't know who these guys were but he
saw that they had money and everyone
treated them with fear and respect for
him a poorly educated angry kid from an
impoverished family a life of crimes who
became the only way new to a better
future one where he wasn't deadbeat but
also wasn't breaking his back 12 hours a
day for some chicken feed by the time he
turned 12 John Gotti already had
developed a reputation as a kid with a
short temper and a pair of Furious Fists
together with his brothers he formed a
gang that terrorized the neighborhood
and soon enough they started running
small errands for the Wise Guys that
he's so creepy admired Gotti was nothing
if not an overachiever and he graduated
pretty fast more serious crime such as
robbery and larceny although they didn't
always go to plan when he was 14 Gotti
tried to steal a cement mixer from a
construction site except that it tipped
over and crushed his toes leaving him
with a permanent limp education took a
back seat in Gotti's life and in 1956 he
dropped out of school altogether the
following year he was arrested for the
first time for getting involved in a
gang fight but it was soon released
without charge a few months later that
unrelated but important event happened
in his future Home Away From Home Albert
Anastasia head of one of the five New
York crime families was assassinated and
Carlo Gambino took over the family that
now shared his name assisted by his
cousin Paul Castellano but these guys
were all big shots at this point John
Gotti was still a small-time crook who
only operated two-bit rackets but he was
starting to meet the right people he
befriended a few future Mobsters like
Angelo regiero and Willie Boy Johnson he
was doing jobs for the Gambino family
Carper Carmine fatico and most important
of all he made the acquaintance of Annie
yellow De La Crosse the future underboss
of the Gambino family in 1963 Gotti went
to jail for the first time except that
it was only for a 20-day stretch for
joyriding in a stolen car despite what
is Teflon Don nickname might suggest
Gotti was not completely impervious to
the occasional Excursion behind bars in
fact he received a more serious rap to
close out the decade after being found
guilty of hijacking some trucks at JFK
International Airport in 1969 Gotti was
sentenced to three years at Lewisburg
Federal Penitentiary and when he got out
in 1972 he went straight back to the
gambino gang even though the arrest cost
Gotti three years of his life ultimately
it benefited him because it showed that
he could do the time already some of his
former running mates like the
aforementioned Willy boy had become
informants for the FBI so the old school
bosses were always on the lookout for
new guys who knew how to keep their
mouths shut in fact when his direct boss
Carmine fatigue got indicted for lone
sharking he appointed Gotti as the
acting boss of their crew who handled
day-to-day operations now Gotti answered
to Lela Croce who saw some of himself
and the young gangster and of it in
Guidance the last the mentorship program
didn't last long because De La Crosse
was hit with multiple charges and in the
early 1970s was sentenced to five years
in prison in 1973. but forgotty this
meant that he now had to deal with the
big boss himself Don Carlo the head of
the Gambino family once again this new
Arrangement was short-lived because that
same year Gotti was indicted on a murder
charge for shooting irish-american
mobster James mcbradney in 1975 he
struck a deal and pled guilty to
manslaughter and only served two years
in a state prison it was a short
sentence but those two years proved to
be crucial because while Gotti was
incarcerated Carlo Gambino died of
natural causes one of the few mob bosses
to enjoy such a privilege and many
people Gotti included expected aniello
de la Croce to become the new boss he
was the underboss after all but that's
not what happened instead Gambino
appointed Paul Castellano aka Big Paulie
as the new head of the family and with
De La Crosse still in prison at the time
he was hardly in an advantageous
position to stake his claim therefore he
had no choice but to accept castellano's
succession with De La Crosse continuing
to serve as underboss once he got out of
prison on the surface the situation
seemed settled but as we all know Still
Waters Run Deep there was a lot of
tension in the Gambino family right now
with the gang effectively splitting into
two factions half-law to De La Crosse
and half loyal to Big Paulie it was only
a matter of time before the situation
would turn bloody now just before we
continue with today's video look you're
a viewer of this channel you're the sort
of person who I bet likes to learn new
things look me too it's one of the very
reasons that we do this channel I'd hate
if you want to take that learning
further then you should definitely check
out the sponsor of today's video
curiosity stream curiosity stream is a
streaming service that isn't filled with
low quality junk and reality TV shows
it's a collection of some of the best
documentary and educational content from
around the world it's available on
whatever devices you happen to have Roku
to Apple TV to Chromecast plus you can
access it worldwide with no Geo
restrictions now one of the neat things
about curiosity stream is that in
addition to their huge library of
existing content they're always adding
cool new documentaries I went and had a
look at what they've recently released
and I added a bunch to my watching you
for example there's this one with the
most clickable title in the world the
moon landing and the Nazis which looks
at what role Nazi technology had in the
journey to the Moon look we've covered a
lot of Nazis on this channel and the
crazy things that they had cooking wild
inventions wise and this documentary
does a deep dive on some of that
technology this is just one random
example of the cool stuff that's being
added all the time so go to
curiositystream.com biographics for
unlimited access to the world's top
documentaries and non-fiction series for
you guys you can use the promo code
biographics and you'll save 25 which
makes it only 14.99 a year which is just
a dollar 25 a month incredible deal
thanks to a curiosity stream for
sponsoring and now back to today's video
[Music]
even though delacrote was not the new
Don he still had plenty of sway so
unsurprisingly once Gotti was out of
prison in 1977 de la Croce made sure
that his former Protege was treated
right first he got made alongside his
brother Jean and friend Angelo riggieri
and then was named as the new captain of
fatico's former crew becoming one of
delacrosse's top earners now that John
Gotti was part of the upper levels of
the mafia hierarchy he took a step back
from riskier crime such as robberies and
hijackings and instead focused on the
traditional mob go-to such as loan
sharking racketeering and gambling but
he was still a violent man who did not
hesitate to get his hands dirty whenever
the situation called for it in 1979 he
made all one of only a handful of
flights in his entire life to travel to
the Tropicana Hotel in Miami Beach
Florida to deal with a loan shark who is
posing a problem for Dela cruso whatever
happens to that guy we don't know we
just assume it was something extremely
unpleasant because he simply disappeared
one day and he was definitely not the
only man in got his life to just vanish
Without a Trace in 1980 a personal
tragedy struck the Gotti household when
the mob Captain's 12-year-old son Frank
Gotti was run over and killed by a
driver the culprit was a neighbor named
John favara and he too disappeared off
the face of the earth a few months later
while John Gotti and his wife Victoria
were away on a convenient Alibi
providing trip to Florida during the
1980s the rift between the two sides of
the Gambino family grew wider many of
the men did not respect big Paulie and
questioned his leadership skills
resenting the fact that he never made
his bones out on the street for his part
Castellano did little to change their
perceptions instead preferring to lock
himself up in his lavish mansion on Todd
Hill and Staten Island and dealing only
with a select few underlings these same
men derisively referred to Castellano as
the pope because he needed a summons in
order to see him and we weren't just
talking about guys loyal to De La Crosse
here even some of Paulie's own guys were
starting to doubt him including
notorious Gambino Soldier Sammy the bull
gravano and big Paul's own consiglieri
Joseph Gallo with that kind of
resistance it was fair to say that
castellano's time at the top would
inevitably come to an end sooner or
later with his back against the ropes
big Paulie tried to play nice with
delacrosso he knew that he was dealing
with an old frail man who was on his way
out and he tried to make good by
promising him that if big poorly went to
jail he would name Gotti as one of the
three Street bosses who would act in his
stead alongside Tommy Gambino Carlo's
son and Tommy billote Paul's favorite
Capo this attempt at mending fence is
actually infuriated got him more than
anything else he saw Tomi Gambino simply
as Carlos spoiled Rich son and Bellotti
as big Paulie's Yes Man neither one was
fit to run the family Gotti became
convinced now more than ever that
Castellano had to go but taken out a
boss wasn't something you could just do
on a whim Gotti had to make sure that he
had the support to take over the family
otherwise he would be taking a dirt nap
right next to Castellano he reached out
to some King members of Paulie's crew
Sammy the bull Frank de C Eco Robert D B
dibernado and Joseph Armani alongside
Gotti himself they had the makings of a
secret conspiracy and they even had a
name for themselves
after they sorted out the issues within
the family they reached out to a few
important members of the other families
in New York Lucchesi Colombo and bonano
and found men who would be amenable if
some unfortunate accident were to befall
big Paulie all except the Genovese since
they were led by Vincent the chin
Gigante a close friend and business
partner of Paul Castellano for decades
on November 2nd 1985 de la Croce died of
cancer foolishly Castellano thought this
represented the golden opportunity for
him to new to Gotti's power without
resorting to violence he immediately
ignored the promises he made named Tommy
belotti as his soul underboss and
disbanded Gotti's crew spreading his men
around the family he even skipped Dela
Cruz's wake out of fear of police
surveillance a disrespectful breach of
etiquette that represented the last
straw Bugatti less than two weeks later
Gotti replied in full force on the
evening of December 16th Castellano and
belotti were driving to spark Steakhouse
in Midtown Manhattan for a meeting the
restaurant had just been named the best
steakhouse in the City by New York
Magazine so big Paulie was probably
looking forward to a really nice dinner
about a dozen men were eagerly awaiting
his arrival but they had ill intentions
in mind four of them were Shooters
shuffling around outside the restaurant
trying to mingle with the Christmas
crowd another six also were back up
Shooters and getaway drivers waiting in
their cars and last but not least there
were two more men sitting in a black
Lincoln in a secluded spot getting ready
to watch the show these were Sammy
gravano and John Gotti truth be told
this was a bit of Overkill because big
Paulie never had a chance of escaping
the Ambush as soon as belotti pulled up
in front of Sparks and Castellano
started getting out of the car six guns
were pointed at his head and they all
opened fire the other two were for
belotti as the shooters disappeared into
the night and they get away Vehicles
Gotti cruised by the crime scene so he
could admire his handiwork the boss was
dead
John Gotti had just done the unthinkable
he organized an unsanctioned hit on a
New York family boss the last time this
had happened had been almost 30 years
earlier back in 1957 when veto Genovese
and Carlo Gambino led a failed
assassination attempt against Frank
Costello followed by a hit against
Albert Anastasia which was met with far
more success but Genovese and Gambino
were the de facto leaders of the two
most powerful crime families in New York
Gotti was just a capo surely he couldn't
get away with it right personalized
to-do list was to get his own house in
order this started immediately following
the hit on big poorly one of the capos
who were loyal to Gotti Frank DeCicco
met with some of the other capos
including Tommy Gambino and James
failure that same night and gave them
the new lay of the land Paul Castellano
was dead so was Tommy belotti but nobody
else was going to get hurt that was all
that needed to be said if nothing else
marbsters have always been Adept at
conveying messages Within economy of
words that would make Hemingway proud
feila and Gambino or Castellano
loyalists but they understood that Gotti
had big poorly whacked and was making a
play for the leadership position if they
interfered then obviously what happened
to Paulie could happen to them it's not
like they were in a position to argue at
the time so they simply agreed and went
home the public reacted to the
assassination with shock and dismay but
at the same time couldn't look away like
the scene of a gruesome car crash as we
said it had been decades since the New
York mob had been rocked by such a
Brazen act of violence and Disobedience
and the media were more than happy to
Fan the Flames since both the NYPD and
the FBI kept gaulty under tight
surveillance it wasn't hard for the
newsmen to lean on their sources and put
out the story that the crimes were part
of John Gotti's plan to become the new
boss of the Gambino family but it wasn't
just Gotti's actions that made for good
print it was John Gotti himself he was a
lot younger than the other Doms he was
in his mid-40s when he killed Castellano
while the other bosses were all eligible
for senior citizens accounts Paulie
himself was 70 when he bit the big one
words like youthful and dashing were
often used to describe Gotti to the
man's great pleasure as most news
outlets were already proclaiming him the
new boss since then he always made sure
to look his best whenever he was out in
public and just like that the Dapper Don
was born
two days after the hit on big poorly a
meeting took place at a restaurant owned
by Sammy the bull Gotti was there and so
were almost all the other capos in the
Gambino family even though they were
theoretically still investigating what
had happened to Castellano it became
clear to everyone in the room that John
Gotti left the building as the new boss
of the gambino crime family with Frank
to see her acting as his underboss but
then there was the little matter of the
other four families three of them were
pretty cool with it as long as Gotti
never openly admitted what he did since
it was after all a serious violation of
commission rules but the Genovese family
was a problem it was led by Vincent
Gigante who had been not only a longtime
friend a poor Castellano but also a
frequent business partner which meant
that Gotti's actions cost him money and
he wasn't about to let him get away with
it the retaliation came on April the
16th 1986 when Gotti and desico were
supposed to meet one of their capos at
his Club in Bensonhurst while everyone
was inside the Hitman working for
Gigante placed a bomb under seiko's
Buick Electra then when the two men came
outside and entered the car the bomb
went off killing both of them but here's
the rub neither man was John Gotti
unbeknownst to the Hitman Gotti got
detained earlier and never arrived at
the club so desico went alone the other
guy in the car with him was an unlucky
gangster who only joined desico to
retrieve the business card for a lawyer
from his glove compartment the good luck
continued for Gotti as Gigante arranged
another hit with two gunmen from New
Jersey however they got a bit too chatty
on a phone line that had been bugged by
the feds so the authorities stepped in
and arrested them before they were able
to carry out the murder after two failed
attempts Gigante relented and accepted
Gotti's new position after all it's not
like he was a stranger to Breaking
commission rules three decades earlier
he had been the one who carried out the
unsanctioned and unsuccessful hit on
Frank Costello
even though Gotti's position with the
other families might have been squared
he was still feeling the heat from the
law as he was dealing with several cases
pending against him first was a felony
assault booth on a refrigerator
repairman named romwald pietzsek poor
pietek went to the police and even
identified Gotti as his attacker but
back then he had no idea who he was
iding once he realized the grave mistake
that he had just made pietzsek refused
to testify against Gotti one down want
to go the other case pending against God
he was more serious it was a RICO case
which stood for racketeer influenced and
corrupt organizations an act that had
been passed specifically to Target the
bigwigs of the mafia however Gotti had
an ace up his sleeve one of the jurors
George Pape was on his payroll so at
worst he was going to get a mistrial but
Pape managed to convince the other
jurors that doing their civic duty
wasn't worth the threat posed by Gotti
to them and their families after a seven
month long trial the verdict was in not
guilty as the crowds both inside and
outside the courtroom started applauding
and cheering at a time when the
government was actually putting a
serious dent in the mob's active
communities got his acquittals were two
rare defeats for them hence the
mobster's new moniker in the media the
Teflon Don but although John Gotti
seemed Untouchable the same couldn't be
said for the men around him first is
underboss Frank desico was killed with
the car bomb intended for him Robert D B
de Bernardo was killed in 86 on Gotti's
orders while Angelo riguero died of
cancer in 89. meanwhile John Gotti's
brother Gene his Kong zigliere Joseph
gallo and his second underboss Joseph
Armani were all convicted of various
crimes attempt to prison in the late
1980s with nobody else left Gotti made
Sammy the bull gravano his new underboss
this turned out to be the biggest
mistake of his life in 1990 Gotti was
arrested again on numerous counts of
racketeering murder extortion jury
tampering and whatever else the district
attorney could throw at him the FBI and
NYPD worked closely to build an airtight
case against him the judge ordered the
jurors to be kept Anonymous everyone
wanted to take down the Teflon Don
despite all of this John Gotti remained
hopeful after all earlier that same year
he had been acquitted in yet another
case that time for assault and
conspiracy he was 3-0 against the
government ever since he took control of
the Gambino family so he had no reason
to think that this time would be any
different but then his heart sank as he
saw on the witness stand none other than
his right hand Man Sammy the bull
gravano had turned States witness
against his former boss and had accepted
witness protection in exchange for
revealing where all the bodies were
buried sometimes quite literally Sammy
the bull admitted to playing a role in
19 killings and indicated his boss in
several of them plus all the other dirt
that he had on him back then this was
the highest ranking desertion in the
mafia's history the second in command of
the most powerful of New York's five
families apparently gravano had been
persuaded to become an informant after
the feds showed him surveillance footage
of Gotti making disparaging remarks
about him and even floating the idea of
letting him take the fall of someone got
his own crimes there was no escaping
this time with all the evidence gathered
by the authorities and Wiz gravano's
testimony John got he was found guilty
of all charges and sentenced to life in
prison in June 1992. he never ceded his
position as head of the Gambino family
instead preferring to relay his orders
through his son John a gotti and his
brother Peter who both served as acting
bosses he spent 10 years in jail before
dying of throat cancer on June 10 2002.
when he was finally found guilty the
head of the FBI's New York office
proudly proclaimed the Teflon is gone
the dawn is covered in velcro and all
the charges stuck